d'alès car il faut encore évoqué ce qui
s'est passé dans l'après midi de ce
samedi les garde frontières de
l'allemagne de l'est ont reçu face au
désordre l'ordre n'ont pas de
reconstruire le mur mais de tenter de
remettre un peu d'ordre de ne pas
laisser cette fracture continuer à
s'ouvrir sans contrôle et ça nous
l'avons vu sur des images comme monté
par la guerre sous les yeux des
garde-frontière est-allemand impassible
en position sur le mur
ce matin vers 6h côté ouest on voulait
abattre le symbole pratiquer le plus de
passage possible après que les forces de
l'ordre
west berlinoise soit intervenu pour
refouler les manifestants qui avaient
arraché une plaque de béton
le dispositif de protection a été
renforcée les vopos ont remis en place
la plaque de béton côté est
on répare pas de remise en cause des
ouvertures seront pratiquées des points
de passages aménagés mais dans l'ordre
quelques heures plus tard sur les lieux
cette scène incroyable un journaliste
ouest allemand termine son reportage en
essayant d'interviewer un
garde-frontière vous pouvez nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé ici ce matin
vous ne pouvez pas nous dire où vous
n'êtes pas prêt sans avoir obtenu la
moindre réponse
le journaliste termine en disant
peut-être que nous avons encore
apprendre à nous comprendre les uns les
autres